bien vous l'aurez compris la gauche du
germes l'utilisation par le gouvernement
de l'article 44 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution une gauche qui a décidé de
le rappeler à chacune de ces prises de
parole depuis ce matin Quentin vous avez
décidé de dévitaliser la fonction
parlementaire par l'addition de toutes
les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez sans doute que nous laissions
la retraite des Français entre les mains
des droites coalisées nous sommes pas
dupe et les Français n'ont plus ne
lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons pas
vous avez décidé de dévitaliser la
fonction parlementaire par l'addition de
toutes les procédures que vous offre la
constitution et le règlement vous
espériez
que nous laissions le sujet des
retraites et les retraites des Français
entre les seuls mains vont seulement des
droits de coalisées mais nous ne sommes
pas dupe et les Français non plus nous
ne lâcherons rien nous ne les lâcherons
pas
[Musique]